خبراء التنميه والاسكان يرون انه من
المتوقع ان يزيد عدد سكان القطاع باكثر من
الضعف في غضون الثلاثين عاما المقبله
ليقارب خمسه ملايين نسمه وسط شح في
الاراضي غير الماهوله التي بدات في النفاذ
فهل سيكون اعمار البحر حلا من الحلول
المستقبليه
التوسع في البحر هو ضمن الحلول الابداعيه
التي تنتهيجها العديد من دول العالم ذات
المساحه الصغيره والضيقه مثل قطاع غزه
ولكن نحن في قطاع غزه المحاصر هناك نقص في
الامكانيات ونحتاج الى العديد من الخبرات
اللازمه من اجل وضع حلول في ردم البحر
سيما اننا نواجه نتيجه التغيرات المناخيه
نواجه تاكل في الشاطئ من يعني اقصى الشمال
الى اقصى الجنوب
[موسيقى]
الحروب والبطاله المتفشيه بين الشباب
وغياب التخطيط ووضع الخطط الاستراتيجيه
الفاعله لحل مشكلات قطاع غزه ومنها ازمه
السكن كلها كانت لها تداعيات خطيره على
حياه المواطن الغزاوي في غياب واضح من قبل
الجهات المسؤوله عن وضع استراتيجيه
لمعالجه ازمه السكن في قطاع غزه وازمه
الاسر الفقيره والبطاله والفقر وبالتالي
هذا هو الذي فاقم من ظهور هذه المشكله
وباتت على السطح بشكل كبير نحن نتحدث
اليوم ان الشعب الفلسطيني تقريبا ثلث
الشعب الفلسطيني او بالتحديد 41% من سكان
قطاع غزه هم دون ال15 وبالتالي من المتوقع
ان تزداد ازمه السكن بعد خمس او عشر سنوات
بشكل كبير جدا ان لم يكن هناك مخطط واضح
ويتم ضمن اسس علميه لم ازمه الاسكان في
قطاع غزه انا بتوقع انه لسه قليله القادمه
الازمه ستكون اكبر واكبر وبالتحديد في
قطاع غزه
هذا الجيب الساحلي الصغير يعاني من تنامي
الكثافه السكانيه بشكل مضطرد وقله
المساحات لاستيعاب هذا الاكتظاظ السكاني
ما يدفع المسؤولين عن القطاع الى ضروره
التفكير في استغلال مساحات فارغه لكنها
قريبه من الحدود مع اسرائيل لرفع المعاناه
عن كاهل الفقراء في غزه الذين يحلمون بسكن
لائق وانساني لاولادهما يعني حقيقه ان
يعني قطاع غزه منطقه ضيقه وهناك انفجار
سكاني حادث وهو بحاجه الى حلول سياسيه يجب
ان يتم توسيع القطاع يجب استعاده اراضينا
المحتله حتى يعيش ابناء قطاع غزه يعني
بسلام وامان